and with the news of fully vaccinated
people no longer having to wear face
coverings where does that leave places
like our resorts and our casinos
madison kimbrough has the latest on what
many on the strip are doing
and how guests feel about this new
guidance madison
yes several properties on the las vegas
strip have already adopted these new
guidelines from the mgm properties that
you're looking at right now
caesar's properties to the cosmopolitan
win encore venetian palazzo
while some guests welcome the change
others say they are keeping their masks
on for now i always wear my mask inside
you don't know who's going to be
vaccinated and so you just continue to
do what's right for you
resorts on the strip immediately jumping
on board with the cdc guidance
so how are visitors feeling about this
it's like 50 50.
we mask up inside if we're in crowded
areas but outside
it's you know we feel all right about it
we're vaccinated can't really tell who's
been vaccinated or not
so i mean like we were walking around
without mass we're not vaccinated i'm
not taking that chance with nobody else
especially my grandma
or older people and stuff like that i
don't want them to catch it
just because i came out here vacationing
while many of these resorts and casinos
are adopting the honor code
not asking for proof of vaccination for
guests employees at mgm
and the venetian will continue to mask
up even if they have received their
vaccine
and the stores inside of the resorts can
still implement mask regulations
so yesterday i had a gentleman at my
work was
telling everybody they could take off
their mass because of the cdc lifting
which is kind of like an inconvenience
for us because
our store still has the mandate
now i also reached out to station
casinos and boyd gaming i'm waiting to
hear back
i did go inside several strip properties
today
and what i saw was about half were
wearing their masks people just walking
around
while a lot of the employees were also
masked up as well reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now